so every time I hit a milestone it
wasn't a celebration it was just like
yes keep going every step because they
waiting on us to follow it took the easy
way out I don't deserve a day that's it
too easy now easy
[Music]
this is no cuz it ain't never had no
music championship or not I got to
perfect my craft and so I can't play no
more need motivation watch a top ten
that believe mission what's that believe
nation it seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent add
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up as
an unusually tall kid reaching six feet
in just middle school to becoming a
two-time NBA champion and one of the
best basketball players in the world
he's Kevin Durant and here's my take on
his top ten Rose success vol 2 joy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one my personal favorite chase your
dream I didn't think I would be in the
NBA
doesn't know for sure
I didn't plan on anything else since I
was like nine
[Music]
I was humble enough to know that it may
not happen but I was arrogant enough to
be late I have no choice but to be
understood a journey at an early age
suit my first goal was to make the
varsity team
I did
second goal was to like start on varsity
and be leader tablespoon did that my
sophomore year what his staff during
show time
my college role was go to college a
big-time college and played Division one
I did that so I said goes along the way
and hit him quick and I thought and it
not smiles I hope I'm on a nice little
trajectory Murray is inserted back
goodbye Ruby 2 seconds left KD
the doubt rule number two keep pushing
by the time you are in high school
everybody knew who you weren't this
truth of the matter and your
neighbourhood people who don't like
greatness they envy it yeah and that's
the pressure you feel you know because
you want proving them wrong so bad but
at the end of the day you're really just
trying to prove yourself right so when
you start to think about you know the
pressure and the hate and all that stuff
it just adds on and it distracts you
from where you're trying to go but I
knew I had to keep pushing so every time
I hit a milestone it wasn't a
celebration it was just like yes keep
going at the step because they waiting
on us to follow
rule number three focus on the right
things
what have you learned over this pass
here because you haven't what happened
in your life I can't worry about what
people say I can't let that distract me
when I want to court play it and it has
before no lie has but can't worry about
what they'll say after the game or how
I'm playing I just got to go play let
the work take control let the work take
over I got away from the love of the
game because I let the business of the
game take I let it I let it be one day I
want to be instead of that in basketball
just be number one think that stuff
doesn't even matter
in just a guard step breaking rule
number four be tough for like I've been
getting bullied over here I took the
easy way out I don't deserve any day
that's it too easy without easy
this isn't your cousin ain't never had
no easy way
[Music]
there is no doubt in my mind it was a
crushing day for him when he knew that
the decision he had to make would be to
go to Golden State because he would
never want anybody there to think that
he didn't appreciate him that he didn't
mean every word he had ever spoken when
he was there kevin gave nine years to
OKC it's a long time and he gave
everything he had the tough decision was
made and you grow from it you learned
from it it's how you handle it we had a
lot of great moments together it's hard
to make it at the top of your profession
no matter what it is but it's easy for
people to describe this like Maggie
Ward's whole life to get to this point
and sometimes I don't even enjoy it
because you work with other people got
to sit SS struggling some days
especially when you play an NBA where
all you hear is the noise it's hard to
tune it out as much as people want us to
like be tough mine have thick skin
sometimes it's hard to light not take us
for yourself
yo work hard as hell you know we're not
in the gym after shooting round we have
two practices you know what's going on
to my head my day before a game I don't
know it's just a game as some people who
did be real life to it I think people
get this idea that like he made his
decision and then on July 4th he was
like bring out the ace of spades let's
pop champagne I'm going to go on stay I
mean it was the opposite like it's July
4th BBQ didn't exist like there was no
celebration he was in more pain making
that decision than anybody because that
was the opposite of what he had done his
whole life which was make sure that
everybody was happy
[Music]
excellent deepest physical games had
their chances says Durant sacks at all
but two
warriors go up a dozen with 55.9
remaining
rule number five stay true to yourself
what's the best thing that you've
learned over the course of this journey
man I had just staying true to yourself
trying to find out who you are and
through my years in high school I always
moved at my own pace and once I got to
the league I started moving at everybody
else's pace and I was I got older I
realized I was it was just too tiring
for me to live a different way and
they're not really I wanted to you know
in the public and how I am private and
it's like I was just struggling with
that so as I got older I just learned
she'd be more authentic more true to
myself hold on to those core values
rule number six be present I would like
to be remembered as a guy that was just
that was just there that was present you
know you can kind of be somewhere and
not be present I want to be I want to be
there and when I when I see when we meet
when we talk I want to I want you to
know that I really cared I'm really
genuine about it and sometimes that
doesn't come off well especially with
people of our statute that don't come
around our communities a lot but I want
them to know that we still care we're
still there you know we got our thing
going on but we also still a partner's
community emotionally and that goes a
long long way more so than what we can
do from our pockets and for me that's
something that I try to do every single
chance that I get and and also on top of
that find creative ways to influence the
community and try to elevate the
community and you know just try to make
it a full thing instead of just I want
to give money and move on it's more of a
it's more of a life thing and I think
it's gonna help you know down the line
and help the kids become something that
they always wanted to be
tradesmen atrocity roses
rule number seven work hard I work so
hard I worked tirelessly so it's easy to
just try to survive
we don't see the work and you know just
look at there's a losses in this shots
made shots all that matters in which you
don't see that's the stuff that matters
as it's the kids and I just keep
building on that foundation I laid out
20 years ago I'm trying to make a batch
you know I'm down there there
[Music]
rule number eight get out of your own
way pay for what they live it like we
all live in such these big bubbles like
for us like me I usually think this is
this world was the end-all beyond like
man if I have a bad game find a bad
stretch I'm like really filling it I had
to really get on my own way it's hard
for people to do that that's what really
that's why they can't you know take a
different way they don't like change
it's like your ego is so big and that
you stuck on what you want to do and how
you view things that you can't get out
your own way elevate and for us it's
just like it's not that big of a deal
like we play basketball imagine me
filling away because this dude that roof
Chris want to go work at Morgan's you
know say look how stupid that sounds for
me able to just have my focus on that
and it's like once you realize that it
makes it it makes things more clearer
and it just realize what you're really
in it for is not it's just for you to
actually do what makes you happy every
day
[Music]
by Marie's ahead like to race first time
I've seen in a long time but God blocks
it whites take a look at covered the red
the first I blocked it slaps it again
rule number nine perfect your craft and
got your ring what's next to you getting
better headway playing basketball I mean
my job was to perfect my craft and
championship or not I got to perfect my
craft hence I can't play no more and
then that's when I'll sit down at the
table and reflect on my career back in
transition
[Applause]
but he wasn't going to take any
prisoners on this one annual number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is have fun are you listening
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
champion of the ball rebound
incredible opportunity for truth that's
good habit I ran from downtown the
Golden State takes the lead Kevin Durant
though so gifted comes down and just
pulls up and knocks it in
[Music]
I've got a really special bonus KD clip
around giving back that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that I want to
know which of these two messages
resonated more with you work hard or be
present let me know leaving the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
obviously being the MBA is a amazing
dream of mine as a kid that's all I
wanted to do but as I got older I
realized the impact that we all have
it's not only just basketball players
but ask people to impact somebody's
lives and so to do this is my way of
giving back and letting you guys know
that the dream is always alive is always
real
so always believe in yourself and that's
what if something as small as a
basketball court did for me hopefully
I'm giving it back to you guys
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I have Tulsa
what a wail out of handcuffed lightning
throw thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and five minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access